larry's from New York and I'm from Los
Angeles so Brooklyn I'm from the valley
he likes to think that I'm some kind of
anti-social psycho the wonder buddy can
you beat the FBI the CIA Walmart when
he's really happy right yeah sounds
because again
yeah why not it's good it rent this
thing online
apparently green tea is very healthy hey
Chuck just feel man oh thank you my
friend thank you my friend
you know green tea black tea and white
tea or actually all from the same plant
feel just like he sounds like this when
I get her on the phone she imitating my
vocal fry just like the yeah how's your
day going oh that's good
that's pretty good hold on hold on she's
always oh hello I'm busy how's it going
when I come over for dinner later I'm
driving
oh [ __ ] what damn it you know Robert
wait a minute what are you gonna do come
on it's okay
you can do it come on over here in the
Pontiac come on when you were [ __ ]
[ __ ] look no hands
and then he'd drive with his knees come
on come on and then like you know some
like old lady's tryin across the seats
like aw great
I wonder why that person is so upset
it's just not worth it to get your blood
pressure up talk to him go to the hand
Hey look at this talk to the head haha
apologies you know I can't talk to you
right now okay let me alone leave me
alone whatever yellow okay close at all
and that's it I raised you [ __ ]
better than this
anyways you need to just like I put up
with this kind of [ __ ] I'm a little
disappointed I really need to talk about
this right now
and you tell me exactly exactly what
happened
hey guess what just happened
bad bad hey mommy look look hey you shut
up
check this deal oh yeah okay when people
do that not how I did cut a light airy
taking it all in you know high as you go
okay one block you've got like a major
white man's underlying happening I think
it's sexy it's means that's it you're my
dad dad well it goes like this he like
really likes doing funny things with his
legs and then like his arms you do like
this hey any but a lot of your mugging
mama as a parent you kind of have these
vignettes of memories over done we're so
much alike in so many ways it's like let
me just do me and but you know with a
different voice you know you're a
certain way but like when you hear
somebody else telling you that you're
that way sometimes it's like a little
bit like like yeah I am that way I love
you me too
take your little [ __ ] - learned